there are a lot of myths in our politics
a lot of legends here's here's one of
the most predominant
myths today
that on january 6
a day that will live in infamy on
january 6 the terrorist insurrectionists
almost
conquered the united states
thomas
conover
remember that name thomas conover
of texas
he was one of the insurrectionists
from january 6. so he's on trial now
and there
well evidence from his trial is now
coming out photographs of him that day
photographs of him smiling thumbs up
sipping a coors light yes that's right
remember that face
remember that face of that terrorist
the men that that logger sipping monster
who nearly brought the global hegemon to
its knees does he if you're watching
this right now
does this guy look like the kind of
person who's going to bring the world
superpower crumbling down
or does he look like a
sort of excited and eccentric
political activist who made it into the
capital was was up to such surreptitious
sedition
seditious activities that he was taking
photos
sipping his coors light
and then he sort of left
he's been charged he's been charged not
with drinking watered down beer he's
been charged with four misdemeanors
including entering restricted grounds
disorderly conduct and unlawful protest
in the capital he has not yet entered a
plea christmas is right around the
corner and you deserve a gift and even
if you don't deserve a gift well
it's the time for giving and charity and
so you know you should get one anyway
how about a gift that keeps on giving
you joy and comfort every day all year
long a gift that looks as good as it
feels
a gift that will actually pay for itself
in terms of how much more productive you
will be at work
i'm talking about
giving yourself the gift of an ex chair
i love my ex chair
the x chair is the most incredible piece
of furniture in this office okay it's
this amazing thing it's super cool and
modern looking it uh it's very
comfortable it keeps your posture very
nice
it will massage you
it will either cool you down or warm you
up it is
if you want to get a massage in the
office and not worry about an hr
violation
check out exterior today here is x
cheers christmas gift for you save 100
off your exterior by purchasing it at
xcheerknowles.com right now that is x
the letter x chair
knowles kwles.com
xtra is a 30-day guarantee of complete
comfort you can finance your purchase
for as little as 30 bucks a month go
right now to
xchairknowles.com and save externals.com
the libs did not want us to see these
photos
the libs
wanted us to believe that this was a
well-organized terrorist group that went
in armed to the hilt they weren't armed
by the way but that they were armed to
the hilt and they were killing people
and killing cops and taking over the
country didn't happen the only person
who was killed in the political violence
was one of the
right wingers was ashley babbitt who was
killed by a cop
air force veteran ashley babbitt
they didn't want us to see these photos
because the photos contradict the
narrative you can't look at these photos
and say this was
the insurrection to take down the
country it wasn't
might have been eccentric people
might have been disorderly
maybe they deserve to be charged with
these misdemeanors or whatever you know
what they don't deserve to be thrown in
solitary confinement for months and
months on end you know what they don't
deserve to be called traitors and
seditionists and terrorists
because they manifestly are not those
things
so the best they've got
disorderly conduct unlawful protest in
the capital
how many libs have done that
in just the last
five ten years
how many times has there been some group
of crazy libs whether it was the pink
shirt ladies or the pink hat ladies or
what the left wingers breaking and
screaming interrupting senate testimony
into breaking into how many times has
that happened countless times just in my
own life
but but they face very few consequences
if any and then the conservatives who do
it the right wingers who do it get the
book thrown at them this is what is so
wrong about what's going on with january
6th
is it's not that the the january 6
people didn't do anything wrong i guess
it's probably not legal to sip a course
outside right that's probably not
legal either
it's not that it's completely innocent
people in on completely made-up charges
it's that it's people who are in on
extremely trumped-up charges
that's why they're the nearest thing to
political dissidence that we have in the
united states and the libs have to keep
up this narrative that their got when
their guys burn down the country for six
months that's good they're mostly
peaceful protesters and when
a dude shows up sipping a coors light
taking pictures in the capital rotunda
he's a terrorist who should be sent to
guantanamo bay i am really glad you like
that clip i am
i i could not be i could be happier
here's how i could be happier
ring the bell
please i would appreciate it if you ring
the bell you get the notifications you
should also go to apple podcast spotify
stitcher google play wherever you get
your audio podcast you can type in the
michael knowles show subscribe maybe
leave a five-star review if you wouldn't
mind and i'll see you next time
[Music]
[Music]